it is June 10th 2023 and you are
watching the code report there's
millions of great JavaScript Frameworks
in the world today but the most popular
choice is still react even though we
have faster Alternatives like solid
preact and quick that also use jsx one
of react's original Innovations was the
virtual Dom but many modern Frameworks
have moved away from this approach and
Rich Harris the creator of svelte once
called it pure overhead despite this
react will likely still be used on
websites hundreds of years after we're
all dead but today I have some good news
a recent high school graduate named
Aiden by just improved reacts
performance by 70 percent with million
JS which provides a hyper optimized
virtual Dom and chains the original
virtual Dom to the radiator where it
can't cause any problems when I first
saw this my initial thought was no way
there's no way a teenager could
outrender an entire team of top tier
engineers at meta but there are
benchmarks to back up these outrageous
claims like on the gold standard
framework Benchmark it ranks way higher
than react itself and even beats
solid.js and it provides a live demo
where you can compare react and millions
side by side now it's important to point
out that benchmarks don't really
represent real world use cases and the
vast majority of web apps out there will
never get to the point where they have
rendering issues with a JavaScript
framework however it's always fun to do
some premature over optimization anyway
but if you're a highly experienced react
developer you might be wondering what is
the virtual Dom I've never heard of it
well to update things in the UI react
makes a lightweight copy of the Dom
where it can calculate updates faster
and then update everything all at once
it's kind of like finalizing all your
changes on a blueprint before you go
tearing out walls in a building but all
this happens at runtime and there's a
lot of unnecessary work trying to figure
out what changed million JS takes a more
surgical approach by introducing a
compiler that can perform static
analysis to figure out exactly where the
dynamic data is in advance it creates an
edit map to represent the state of the
application which can then determine
what has changed with far less
computation required this approach is
inspired by other Frameworks like svelt
and solid which also rely on a compiler
to achieve these surgical Dom updates
and million was also inspired by the
prior work of a library called block Dom
what's also cool about million is that
it's only four kilobytes and extremely
easy to use use all you do is take an
existing react component and wrap it
inside this block function to create a
higher order component which will block
out the virtual Dom and let million
magically take over basically after the
component is mounted it makes a
reference to the underlying Dom element
then does all the subsequent rendering
and change detection on its own in
addition it has a built-in 4 component
which is used to render a list of blocks
pretty simple but before you get too
excited the creator of this project
admits that it's not a silver bullet
when using blocks you need to follow a
specific set of rules and if you break
those rules it'll revert back to reacts
virtual Dom and you'll lose all your
massive gains overall million JS looks
like an awesome project but most
importantly it gives me hope that gen Z
is not actually Tech illiterate and
might actually one day be able to fix
react this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one